it's been famously said that America
isn't really a melting pot but a savory
stew where traditions from around the
world help form our national character
and that's true of our culinary heritage
as well this morning on the dish we
visit a restaurant that hit its stride
by bringing a taste of West Africa to
our nation's capital the restaurant
opened chrome may be unassuming with
space for just a few and I take out
focused business but the food it serves
is captivating a fusion of traditional
African Ghanaian dishes with
Mediterranean and American influences
like red snapper with beans and
plantains and a fried chicken sandwich
served on milk buns baked here daily I
don't think you can find the same
flavors here and somewhere else because
I make everything in-house you can't
really duplicate it
Peter Aparri is both chef and co-owner
he got the name open Crum from a baking
term used to describe the inside of
breads and cakes and in this case it's
also home for Peter who lives right
upstairs I feel like if you walk in here
since I do kind of live here you're kind
of walking into my home and he's always
been most at home in the kitchen I
remember the first time I put myself in
the position to use my mom was cooking
in the back of our first restaurant I
remember they were just being a pile of
dishes and I just started washing them
that was in the mid 90s after a
two-year-old Peter had moved with his
parents from Ghana to the United States
they opened a coffee shop which
eventually turned into an African
restaurant as the family business grew
Peter and his two brothers had a
front-row seat for it all did you think
though that it would be a career for you
oh god no I ran away from him
I had my heart set on med school I was
like I'm gonna be a doctor and through
all the steps how did you end up here
why did you medicine for I just like I'm
not gonna be happy doing this how did
you know that food was the place for you
I did it but when you start talking
about food so much and when food is like
one of the conversation that comes up
all the time salivating over the idea of
buying a KitchenAid that's when this
kitchen came into play about two years
ago Peters parents were using it to make
prepackaged and hotbar items for Whole
Foods and offered the front of it that
small restaurant space to Peter it
scared me I don't get really why because
it's like something I never was in the
front of I've never cooked
professionally at this level by myself
it took me some time to gain that
confidence why did you trust him because
Peter has always loved to cook since the
age of five the family business turned
family legacy it's second nature to me
like Jimi Hendrix his dad taught him how
to play guitar and he was blessed with
that so I have that same privilege of
having my mom teach me how to cook
and growing up in a commercial kitchen
hands-on learning I never really need to
go to culinary school since I grew up in
culinary school that education continues
Peter regularly pulls from his mom's
knowledge of African food and restaurant
know-how
she's even been finally referred to as
the general even though I run the
kitchen I've make the menu she runs
things it's about the emotion behind it
when you're eating it I want to make
other people really happy with my food
I've also grew up in a family of food
was always like joy and like love and
attention and care because we always
took our time with it it's the thing
that brings you together and Peter
doesn't think people should have to pay
a fortune to experience that it feels
like you reflect the neighborhood a
little bit that neighborhood is
Anacostia in Southeast Washington DC
once home to Frederick Douglass the
area's rich in african-american history
and culture but lacks financial wealth
and is exactly where the Aparri family
wants to be why for you is it important
not just to be here but to have a
restaurant here that people can enjoy in
this community because I think we've
lost so many of them especially black
owned restaurants in this community we
need something that represents people if
it's not African culture or black
American culture you need something that
represents them represents us I seen
that from this community
really do support and want me to
continue while this neighborhood grows
what do you hope your impact is on the
community I want people to eat better to
have the opportunity to have something
that is hosting I want people to know
that we're here and we're not just here
to like extract from the community we
will actually want to give back it's why
when the corona virus pandemic took its
toll
open Crum began working with three
nonprofits to provide more than 300
meals a week for those who need the most
that's hard for businesses to do at a
time like this where obviously you
already are being stretched is it it is
but it gives you so much more back
there's more to having a restaurant than
just making money if you can give us
someone a meal and they're hungry that's
something that we should be doing it's
an extension he says of open Crum open
prom to me means technique food should
in my opinion take time this is one of
the most important ingredients that you
have and it's that time and that time
together when you were referencing when
you were a kid yeah it's like my mom's
always taking our time and fear I love
every step when you spend so much time
on something it really does show up that
people feel and taste that love people
do it you can't really duplicate it and
honestly this is a family business
everyone is involved in it in that
community now Jeff is a part of that
family as well just fantastic I want
some of that fish Dana all right really
good stuff it was good